like i don't know what you guys count as
a small wedding
most of the weddings i've been to have
been very much dominated by family
yeah ours is like 80 percent mates
that's good though yeah that's good
that's good yeah so like yeah because
like i know like every small small
weddings or medium-sized wedding is like
different depending on like whatever
culture you're from like you know a
hundred hundred people is like i'd say
like a medium-sized wedding you know
that's that's medium you know 100 people
was like tiny compared to an indian
wedding you know yeah i was talking to
like i was talking to a guy who like
went to an indian wedding and they had
like a thousand people going or
something that's that's a concert
like indian weddings are basically what
happened if you actually go on your
facebook group and you invite everyone
in your friend group
and everyone said yes
yeah yeah right
like i know like part of the reason uh
so we're actually
you know part of the reason because we
do have a massive family but we didn't
want a massive like a massive massive
wedding because that's just like such a
headache so we're just like you know
what we're gonna have the main wedding
in the uk and then we'll be we'll bring
the wedding to the family we'll we'll go
on tour you know what i mean
we'll go on tour the waiting tour
so yeah we're having like we're having
like a different kind of
reception kind of thing for like our
family in the u.s and thailand like you
know way after that'd be nice though
yeah way off here
sorry i'm hitting up all the spots this
is the world line
wedding on tour
now you only had one wedding dude yeah
because cause like i don't know like i i
would i want to be able to talk to
be able to talk to everyone at my
wedding and you know shell at the
positive vibe
when you get over to like 100 or 150
people which yeah it definitely would
have been our wedding if we invited all
of the family from like our beaufort
sites from abroad
um you just like you get to a point
where
it's our wedding it's meant to be like
our happiest moment but you don't get
time to share it with the people that
you want to share right right you know
you see everyone talking but you you
like most of your interactions you're
just like oh you're having a good time
you have like a five minute conversation
and that's it you know it's basically
just like going to a convention you know
and going to like a panel or something
because that's that's the amount of
interaction i have with people who you
know line up for a meet-up or something
yeah i want more of an interaction and
more time to like get to get to vibe
with people at my own [ __ ] wedding i
guess so yeah yeah i don't know i don't
know how people handle like massive
[ __ ] weddings of like you know 300
500 whatever you know yeah cause i've
been to i went to my like um
my friend's wedding like japanese guy
who i went to university with and like
it's a tradition i don't know if it's
like a full-on tradition but like
usually the tradition is like if you
have like a full-time job like you
already have enjoyed your college
happening and like i was on the table of
like mates who i went to school with you
know yeah
but we realized that was one table out
of like
40 tables that were there
because there was like there was
probably like 400 people at this wedding
yeah all work colleagues like all bosses
and like all family and there was just
like me and like three schoolmates who
they've been like yeah so have you
it's been a while i don't know any of
these other people but uh good wedding
yeah
did you have to like line up to give
your blessing because i've i've been to
some weddings where we have to do that
yeah yeah yeah like you have to give
your blessing what's that yeah because
because there is so many people at the
wedding right and the the bride and
groom only have so much time everyone
takes turn lining up so yeah
like i went to a thai wedding where i we
literally had to line up to be like
congratulations guys
they had like the stage where like they
sat on like a [ __ ] sofa or whatever
they've only been to like white people
weddings so i don't i literally had to
line up to like shake my mates yeah
yeah because it was like because like
you know after the reception and
everything and you know during like you
know food and stuff like that and
they're kind of like walking around and
stuff you know saying hello to everyone
yeah like uh yeah good system though
yeah i mean it's a good system but it
was also weird just like lining up next
to like a bunch of salary men to be like
oh yeah i'm just here to shake my mind's
hand you know efficient i like it i like
the efficiency of it yeah
oh you didn't see me with the wedding
shut up we got five minutes in a
handshake
like it's like an idol like yeah it is
like how many of my albums did you buy i
bought 10 of your cds you know you're
just in the in the like wedding
asian weddings as well when you're
lining up sometimes you haven't even
slipped some money to like pass it wow
oh yeah yeah yeah
i don't know if this feels quite insane
but it just feels like the supreme store
of weddings like asian asian weddings
are it's like how much can you flex just
everyone brings it like supreme out
everyone's like oh yeah of course at
this spread dude way more food than
you'd ever need yeah yeah yeah bring
everyone you know why just so i can have
the capacity bigger on facebook
because it's like a lot of asian
weddings i've been to it's it's it's
like a statement you know what i mean
it's it's it's like it's about sending a
i think it's also about like look at how
like happy we are and look at and like
this is like the physical representation
of how like yeah you know happy and like
well off we are for being happy yeah
because like the amount of
wedding politics that go into an asian
it is a thing it is a thing right
because it's it's not even it's not even
about inviting your immediate friends
and family you got like your parents
immediate like friends and family and
people you grew up with and everything
like that there's like
if you are not invited to an asian
wedding
you're [ __ ] up in some way you know
what i mean this legit sounds like the
red wedding from game of thrones it is
you failed to invite me to the wedding
thus you have to portray my clan
you will die now if you have insulted
the house of manitoba
you will not be forgiven for this
which is why i i didn't want i didn't
want like that side just like involved
in my wedding
yeah yeah
there is another
[Laughter]
the scroll comes down we've gotta
appease like the family
[Laughter]
yeah i mean like it's like i've like
every asian wedding i've been to is like
the most extra thing i've ever seen in
the world um and like it's unfortunate
that is also it's also extrapolated by
the fact that every asian family i know
is [ __ ] massive it's absolutely
massive you have to play southeast asia
especially oh my god if like if i had if
i had my wedding inside i don't have to
invite all my cousins and all like my
cousins
my cousins
the entire
um so yeah like that's
that's like i definitely would not have
been able to plan that
um along with just being outside the
country so i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm
just gonna have a small manageable
wedding um and just enjoy it right and
just and just enjoy the wedding yeah
[ __ ] yeah dude yeah that sounds nice i'm
excited for it man did you get like an
overwhelming amount of people in your
twitch chat asking if we were going to
god's wedding or when god's wedding was
as if they're like they're also planning
to go but they were like they were like
you're going to film it right i'm like
no
no
i got that so many times people are like
so this is this is like a trash tape
could you imagine if i just like rocked
up with a [ __ ] camera being like all
right so uh challenging
[ __ ] rocks like the [ __ ]
[ __ ] ten different
video crews just like filming every
angle of this wedding gopro on every
corner of the room
come on it's got like a gopro
[ __ ] forehead like pov
four out of five
review of all the free drinks yeah i
mean like
it was actually like i barely
took any pictures at the wedding i
attended like because one you know i won
i just felt like you know we have we
have some pictures but it was more
pictures to share in between our mates
and you know we might we'll probably
share yeah me and cindy will probably
show the wedding
yeah i don't know how much we're gonna
share to social media yeah i don't know
yet you know it's kind of it's kind of
i'll decide i'll be wearing a suit and
suddenly wearing a dress
yeah
that's pretty yeah
and everyone will be nice
it's not gonna be any different just
because really youtubers who are not
like yeah whoa
there have been like other youtubers who
have you know very much documented their
wedding and you know everyone's
different in terms of choosing how much
they wish to share you know it's
entirely up to everyone but you have to
understand that everyone's a bit
different in terms of how much they
choose to share
um because it is a very private event
yeah you gotta respect the privacy it's
it's a wedding so the way i see about it
is that you know i'm only gonna get like
one wedding in my life so how much of
this do i want to share over the world
how much of this do i want to keep
between myself and my close mates and
family yeah i don't know yet i don't
know yeah i'll i'll think about it and
we'll decide content
yeah because because like what are your
one wedding calls
like because like you always like you
you always you always have to battle the
thought of like you know that whatever
you post it's going to get like the most
engagement oh yeah
of course that you're ever going to get
yourself if i post a video of this i
know it's going to get [ __ ] like 2-3
million views man easy easy and that's
that that's free content you know i
don't even have to i'm gonna do it
anyway that's just free content
it's like honey i know this is like a
really like personal thing but that
click right through them like what's up
guys i'm in the altar with the boys
seven mid roles on that [ __ ]
my god my full jump into that i'm not
sponsored
it might be a good place to actually put
it i don't know
bro imagine if we like [ __ ] live
stream that imagine the [ __ ] super
chats man
like youtubers could like v v2 biscuit
you could dream of getting the super
chats
please gaunt will not say his vows until
we get at least two grand
wow we are not moving from this spot